right now the bureau of land management
is hosting a virtual public meeting to
talk about possibly make some changes to
a very popular hiking spot calico basin
and red rock conservation area is a free
alternative to the scenic loop but that
could change joe mohler is live near red
rock with what the plan is on the table
tonight joe
the bureau of land management is hosting
that meeting right now to get
information out there about this plan
and to get feedback from the public
calico basin is a very popular spot here
in red rock and the blm wants to
preserve it
it's beautiful there's a lot of climbing
people come to calico basin for a number
of reasons it's nice to get away from
the crowds you don't have to do the
whole red rock loop the price to get in
is the main reason people come here this
is amazing because it's free it was nice
because you don't have to like reserve
or anything like you do at red rock
because you can drive right in it is a
popular place there's plenty to explore
in an effort to preserve calico basin
blm is considering a new management plan
in 2019 700 000 people went to
just the calico basin area and it looks
like we're probably going to get very
close to 900 000 this year john aslin
from blm says they are taking public
comment for the plan that could add an
entry gate with fees and hours of
operation this will help us put in
more infrastructure there which would
include
restrooms back in the craft mountain
area all these little infrastructure
things that we've really needed over the
years visitors we caught up with are not
too happy about fees it just seems like
another barrier to access
just like more hoops to jump through
charging would probably
stop me from coming here some wonder how
this will impact visitors wanting to
come back i think it would be good as
far as conservation goes but as far as
access for a lot of people
it might be a lot tougher
now back out here live public comment
for this does not close until december
8th we have a link so do that up on our
website that is 8newsnow.com you'll also
find the link to the meeting that is
happening right now details regarding
this plan won't be finalized until
january reporting live outside of red
rock joe mueller live local now